la competencia del festival de cine de
cannes comenzó oficialmente con una
cinta histórica y un relato en lo alto
de las montañas
el director ruso kirill cerebro en icon
regresó por la puerta grande al festival
de cannes serebrennikov sobre que
empezaba hasta hace unos meses la
prohibición de salida de su país el
conocido cineasta y opositor al kremlin
está aquí en la competencia con su
última película la esposa de tchaikovsky
un drama histórico sobre la mujer del
célebre compositor ruso
la cinta narra la pasión devoradora
hasta la locura de esta mujer antonina y
su matrimonio desastroso con tchaikovsky
en el siglo 19 pero también la sumisión
de las mujeres y la alienación a los
valores patrióticos
[Música]
más también en la competencia este año
en cannes las 8 montañas una cinta ítalo
belga filmada a cuatro manos
[Música]
las ocho montañas narra la amistad entre
pietro y bruno en un paraíso de
naturaleza una cinta lenta que
transcurre desde la infancia hasta la
adultez entre estos dos amigos que
construyen un jardín secreto en lo alto
de las montañas
cannes deliro con la presencia de la
superestrella de hollywood tom cruise
quien vino a la alfombra roja de cannes
para presentar su última película top
con maverick 36 años después de esa
primera película que se volvió de culto
[Música]
los fanáticos gritaron cuando tom cruise
llegó al palacio de los festivales donde
recibió una palma de oro de honor y fue
homenajeado por la patrulla de francia
[Aplausos]